From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. One day, when I was 14, coming home from junior high school, I saw my across-the-street neighbor, [? Mark Nasdor, ?] and he was riding his 10-speed down this big hill near our school. I was near the bottom of the hill. And I had one of those-- you know those three-ring binders that you use when you're in school, those loose leaf binders? I had one of those, with all my school papers in it.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我14岁那年的一天，从初中回家的路上，看到住在街对面的邻居马克·纳斯多（音译），他正骑着十速自行车从学校附近的一座大坡上冲下来。我当时就在坡底。我手里拿着那种——你知道学生用的三环活页夹吗？就是那种活页笔记本。我手里正拿着一个，里面塞满了学校的作业。
And as [? Mark Nasdor ?] sped down the sidewalk of this very steep hill, I got this idea. And to explain this, I need you to picture for a second what a loose leaf binder looks like when you lay it on the ground. it looks like a little ramp, right, with the highest point of the ramp being the fatter side, the side with the rings. And I thought, I could throw my loose leaf notebook in front of Mark's moving bicycle, positioning it perfectly so his wheels would roll up the ramp. And it would serve as a ramp. He would fly in the air like Evel Knievel.
就在马克·纳斯多飞快地沿着陡坡的人行道骑下来时，我突然冒出了一个念头。为了解释清楚，你需要想象一下，当一个活页夹平放在地上时是什么样子。它看起来像个小斜坡，对吧？最高点是较厚的一侧，也就是有圆环的那边。我想，我可以把我的活页笔记本扔到马克那辆正在移动的自行车前，位置摆得刚刚好，这样他的车轮就会滚上斜坡。它会充当一个跳台，他就能像伊夫·克尼弗尔那样飞向空中。
Now, I want to say [UNINTELLIGIBLE] about speed. This idea popped into my head. And then in a second, too fast to actually think this through-- if there were time to think about this, I don't think I would have done it-- the idea pops into my head, and then there is [? Mark Nasdor, ?] moving fast down this hill. And I threw the binder in front of him.
现在，关于速度，我想说（难以听清）。这个念头闪过我的脑海。接着，在一瞬间，快到根本来不及细想——如果当时有时间思考，我想我是不会那么做的——念头出现了，然后，马克·纳斯多正飞快地沿着山坡冲下来。于是，我把笔记本扔到了他面前。
Now, in case you're wondering what the actual aerodynamics are when a moving bicycle meets a junior high school binder, and how high the bike flies, and how far it goes, I can tell you, because I was there, I saw this. What happens to a bicycle in this situation is it flips on its side at a very high speed, throwing the bicyclist off and bruising the bicyclist. The bicyclist then gets up, curses at you, and asks this question, "Why did you do that?"
现在，如果你想知道当一辆行驶中的自行车遇到一个初中生的笔记本时，真正的空气动力学原理是什么，自行车能飞多高，能飞多远，我可以告诉你，因为我就在现场，我亲眼看到了。在这种情况下，自行车会以极高的速度侧翻，将骑车人甩出去并弄伤他。接着，骑车人会爬起来，骂你一顿，并问这个问题：“你为什么要那样做？”
It's a good question. It's a really good question. And I had no answer at the time. I do now, because I heard some things lately that shed some light.
这是一个好问题。这是一个非常好的问题。当时我给不出答案。现在我知道了，因为我最近听到了一些能给我启发的事情。
I was seven years old when this happened. All of my life, my family would go to this campground for the whole summer.
我七岁那年发生了这件事。我从小到大，家里整个夏天都会去那个露营地。
This is Wendy.
这是温迪。
In this campground, all of the teen-- my sister was a teenager at the time. She was 17 at the time. All the teenagers at this campground, on Friday nights, before they would go out, they would go up to this place, this barn. It had video games in it, and there was a little place where you could buy penny candy. And one of these Friday nights, I went with my sister up to the barn.
在这个露营地里，所有的青少年——当时我姐姐是青少年，她那时候17岁。每周五晚上，在露营地所有的青少年出去玩之前，他们都会去一个地方，那是一个谷仓。里面有电子游戏，还有一个可以买零食的小地方。在其中的一个周五晚上，我和姐姐去了那个谷仓。
And she had this one friend. And I don't remember her name, but I remember what she looked like. I remember she had this blonde, feathered hair. And she was really pretty. And she had eye shadow and makeup on, and that was kind of fascinating to me.
她有一个朋友。我不记得她的名字了，但我记得她的长相。我记得她留着金色的羽毛剪发型。她非常漂亮。她画着眼影，化着妆，这让我觉得特别着迷。
And she was wearing this orange jumpsuit. And it had the zipper down the front. And it was really-- it just stood out to me. And at some point, I went over, and I was talking to her.
她穿着一件橘色的连体裤，拉链一直拉到胸前。这让我印象特别深。后来，我走过去跟她说话。
And I don't know why I did it. But I just, I had this impulse. And I just said to her, "Close your eyes." And she did.
我不知道我为什么要那么做，但我当时就是有种冲动。我对她说：“闭上眼睛。”她照做了。
And when she closed her eyes, I reached out, and I grabbed the zipper. And I unzipped her jumpsuit all the way down to the belly button. And when I did that, her breasts popped out of the jumpsuit. And I don't know what I was expecting, but I didn't expect them to pop out like they did. She wasn't wearing a bra or anything.
当她闭上眼睛时，我伸出手，抓住了拉链。我把她的连体裤拉链一直拉到了肚脐眼。当我这样做的时候，她的胸部从连体裤里弹了出来。我不知道我当时在期待什么，但我没想到它们会像那样弹出来。她当时没穿胸罩之类的东西。
And she screamed. And she was completely freaked out. And I just ran away. I just ran. I ran back to the camper.
她尖叫起来。她完全被吓坏了。我就跑开了。我跑了。我跑回了露营车那里。
Her sister was furious. Her parents were furious. And they kept asking her, over and over, one simple question.
她的姐姐非常愤怒。她的父母也非常愤怒。他们一遍又一遍地问她一个简单的问题。
Why would you do such a thing? Why would you do this? And I remember crying and saying, I don't know why I did it. I don't know why I did it. I don't know why I did it.
你为什么要那样做？你为什么要那样做？我记得我当时哭着说，我不知道我为什么那样做。我不知道我为什么那样做。我不知道我为什么那样做。
And they kept pushing me, like, why would you do this? Why would you do this? And I had no idea. But I remember being really tortured by it afterwards, thinking, why would I do it? Why did I do that? That doesn't make any sense.
他们不停地追问我，比如，你为什么要这样做？你为什么要这样做？我毫无头绪。但我记得在那之后，我为此感到非常受折磨，心里想，我为什么要那样做？我为什么要那样做？那完全说不通。
Most of us have an idea of what the devil's supposed to be like, red skin, horns, a tail. Sometimes he disguises himself as a dapper gentleman. Often, he loves to sing. And the way that he actually gets you into hell, in the movies, and in operas, and stuff, is that he actually shows up in person. He makes a personal appearance with you, and he tries to talk you into it. He tempts you with stuff that you want.
我们大多数人对于魔鬼的样子都有个概念：红皮肤、长角、有一条尾巴。有时他会伪装成一位衣冠楚楚的绅士。通常，他喜欢唱歌。在电影、歌剧等作品中，他诱骗你下地狱的方式，通常是亲自现身。他会亲自出现在你面前，试图说服你。他会用你想要的东西来引诱你。
Well, there's a way more interesting version of the devil out there in this book by C. S. Lewis called The Screwtape Letters. And the idea of the book is that it's a series of letters from this older, very experienced demon named Screwtape to a much younger demon. And he's giving him advice. And at one point, Screwtape says to the younger demon, if you want to commit somebody's soul to hell for eternity, don't try to reason with them. You don't want to be arguing with somebody about what's good for them or bad for them, because you could lose an argument. What's better, what works way, way better, is to simply banish reason from the room.
好吧，在C.S.刘易斯那本名为《地狱来鸿》的书里，有一个更有趣的魔鬼版本。这本书的构思是一系列由一位年长、非常有经验的恶魔“螺丝带”写给年轻恶魔的信。他在给年轻人提建议。在其中一处，螺丝带对年轻恶魔说，如果你想让某人的灵魂永远堕入地狱，不要试图和他们讲道理。你不想和别人争论什么对他们有益、什么有害，因为你可能会在争论中落败。更好、更有效的方法，是直接把“理智”从他们的思维中剔除出去。
Screwtape tells this story to the young demon about this atheist who one day is in the library. And in the library, the atheist starts mulling over some godly thoughts, very threatening for Screwtape. But rather than engage this guy in an argument over God and goodness and all that sort of stuff, Screwtape simply plants the thought in his head, "It's time for lunch."
螺丝带给年轻恶魔讲了一个故事，说的是一个无神论者有一天在图书馆里。在图书馆里，这个无神论者开始思考一些关于上帝的念头，这对螺丝带来说非常危险。但螺丝带没有与这个人争论关于上帝、善良等等之类的话题，而是简单地在他脑海中植入了一个念头：“该吃午饭了。”
The guy heads outside. The battle's won. If you want to lead people into darkness, you don't want reason to even come into play.
那个人走出了门。战斗胜利了。如果你想把人引入黑暗，你甚至不需要让“理智”参与其中。
I was a sophomore at the University of North Carolina in Greensboro.
我是北卡罗来纳大学格林斯伯勒分校的大二学生。
This is Dave. One night, he was walking home late from campus down a quiet street, an ordinary night.
这是戴夫。一天晚上，他深夜从校园走回家，经过一条安静的街道，那是平凡的一晚。
All of a sudden, I saw a car approaching several blocks away. And it occurred to me that what I should do would be to kneel in the street and be hit by the car. It seemed to make perfect sense to me. And so that's what I did.
突然，我看到几条街外有一辆车开过来。我脑子里冒出一个想法：我应该在街上跪下，然后被那辆车撞。这对我来说似乎完全合情合理。于是我就那么做了。
Wait, you actually went out into the street, and you knelt?
等等，你真的走到街上跪下了？
Yes, in the street. And I waited for the car to run over me.
是的，在街上。我等着那辆车从我身上压过去。
What happened?
发生了什么？
Well, the car drove up, screeched to a stop just in front of me. An older man jumped out of the car and demanded to know what I was doing.
车开了过来，就在我面前刺耳地停住了。一个上了年纪的男人从车里跳出来，大声问我在干什么。
A very good question, I should say.
我得说，这是一个非常好的问题。
Well, and I didn't know. I looked at him, and I said, I don't know. I had no idea. I had no explanation for him.
好吧，我不知道。我看着他，我说，我不知道。我毫无头绪。我对他没有任何解释。
Now, up until that moment that you made the decision, had you been kind of depressed?
那么，在你做出这个决定之前，你当时抑郁吗？
No, I had not. I had never, ever considered suicide. I don't remember being sad, depressed, scared. The thought simply occurred to me. It came out of nowhere. It was a blip. I still today-- what, 25 years later-- don't understand what that was and why I did that.
没有，我没有。我从来、从来没考虑过自杀。我不记得当时感到悲伤、抑郁或害怕。这个念头只是突然出现。它凭空冒了出来。它只是脑海中一闪而过的念头。直到今天——25年过去了——我仍然不明白那是什么，我为什么会那么做。
Sometimes these stories are about big, life-changing things, sometimes about the tiniest things. [? Jonifer ?] was sitting on her couch in Madison, Wisconsin, as her neighbors from across the street walked by outside.
有时候，这些故事关于改变人生的重大事件，有时候则关于极其琐碎的小事。乔尼弗当时正坐在威斯康星州麦迪逊市的沙发上，看着街对面的邻居从门外走过。
Now, ?] I don't know them. They've never said anything. I don't know their names or anything. I turned my head, and I just screamed out the window, "Pigs!" And when I realized what I had done, I couldn't think of why I'd done it.
现在，我并不认识他们。他们从来没说过什么话。我不知道他们的名字之类的。我转过头，对着窗外大喊了一声：“猪！”当我意识到自己做了什么时，我完全想不出我为什么要这样做。
Lisa had just learned the Heimlich maneuver from a pamphlet, and was visiting her boyfriend.
丽莎刚从一本小册子上学会了海姆立克急救法，正在去拜访她的男朋友。
I just went up behind him. And he probably thought I was going to give him a hug. But I just did the whole Heimlich maneuver on him, although he was not choking.
我就走到他身后。他大概以为我要给他一个拥抱。但我直接对他做了海姆立克急救法，尽管他根本没有被噎住。
He must have asked, why'd you do that, right?
他肯定问过，你为什么那样做，对吧？
Yeah. Well, he screamed, because it hurts. And he was just confounded. And I had no answer.
是的。好吧，他尖叫起来，因为那样做很疼。他完全被搞糊涂了。而我给不出答案。
It's hard to believe that there are demons and devils urging us to do wrong. But how many of us have done something bad or wrong or just random, totally random, and have no good explanation for it at all? Well, today on our program, with Halloween approaching, the Devil on Your Shoulder, stories of people who are trying to convince you that the devil is there, and stories of people trying to deny that he's there, against, I have to say in these cases, some heavy evidence.
很难相信真的有恶魔和魔鬼在怂恿我们做错事。但我们中有多少人做过坏事、错事，或者是完全随机的、毫无缘由的事情，却根本没有任何合理的解释？嗯，今天我们的节目，随着万圣节临近，主题是“肩上的魔鬼”，讲述那些试图说服你魔鬼确实存在的人的故事，以及那些试图否认魔鬼存在的人的故事——尽管我必须说，在这些案例中，有相当多的证据摆在眼前。
Act One of our show, It's Fun to Make Hell on Earth. In that act, the story of a Christian youth group in Texas that, for three weeks every year, acts out the worst, the meanest, the most despicable behavior possible, all in the name of saving people from hell. Act Two, Sixteen Candles Can Lead to a Lot of Fire. A young Amish man explains why it is that, after being set free to drink and drive and party at the age of 16, most of his friends choose to go back to the church and back to the Amish lifestyle. Act Three, Devil in Angel's Clothing, or Is It the Other Way Around? the story of a man who did something terrible as a teenager, and then tried to pretend that it never happened for 20 years, and then tried to do something about it, or people tell him he tried to do something about it. He can't remember himself. Stay with us.
我们节目的第一幕，“人间炼狱，其乐无穷”。在那一幕中，讲的是德克萨斯州的一个基督教青年团体，他们每年会花三周时间表演最恶毒、最卑鄙、最令人厌恶的行为，所有这些都是为了拯救人们免于下地狱。第二幕，“十六岁蜡烛可能引发大火”。一位年轻的阿米什人解释说，为什么在16岁被允许喝酒、开车和聚会后，他大多数朋友还是选择了回到教会，回到阿米什人的生活方式。第三幕，“天使外衣下的魔鬼，还是恰恰相反？”这是一个男人在青少年时期做了一件可怕的事，然后试图假装这件事从未发生，过了20年，又试图弥补这件事的故事；或者说，人们告诉他他试图弥补过。他自己记不清了。请留下来。
Act One, It's Fun to Make Hell on Earth. In 1999, documentary filmmaker George Ratliff read about a church in Cedar Hill, Texas, which is a suburb of Dallas, that was staging a re-creation of the Columbine Massacre. That church, Trinity Church, was putting on a haunted house called Hell House. They'd been doing it every year for years, each Halloween.
第一幕，人间炼狱，其乐无穷。1999年，纪录片导演乔治·拉特利夫读到关于德克萨斯州锡达希尔（达拉斯郊区）一家教会的消息，该教会正在重演科伦拜恩枪击案。那家教会——三一教会，正在举办一个名为“地狱屋”的鬼屋活动。多年来，每年的万圣节他们都会这么做。
The Columbine scene was just one scene of about a dozen. There was also an abortion scene. There was a scene where a gay man dies of AIDS, and a scene where a mom meets a man on the internet and then deserts her family for that man.
科伦拜恩的场景只是大约十几个场景中的一个。还有一个堕胎场景。有一个场景是一个男同性恋者死于艾滋病，还有一个场景是一个妈妈在网上认识了一个男人，然后为了那个男人抛弃了家庭。
In each scene, a demon eggs on the sinner. The demon is right there, egging on the bad person. And the point is, devils are around us, trying to trip us up, every day. Sin is real. The devil's real. So you better get right with God.
在每个场景中，都有一个恶魔在怂恿罪人。恶魔就在那里，怂恿那个做坏事的人。重点是，魔鬼就在我们身边，每天都在试图绊倒我们。罪恶是真实的。魔鬼是真实的。所以你最好向上帝认罪。
George Ratliff made a film about it, and he agreed to pull some of his footage to play here on the radio for us. Here he is.
乔治·拉特利夫为此拍了一部电影，他同意提供一些镜头，供我们在电台上播放。他来了。
I showed up at Hell House with my cinematographer friend, Jawad Metni. We were herded around the place with a group of 40 teenagers clinging to each other and laughing nervously. A large man dressed in a black hooded robe and a skeleton mask was assigned to our group as our tour guide.
我和我的摄影师朋友贾瓦德·梅特尼出现在“地狱屋”。我们和一群40名青少年被赶着穿过这里，他们紧紧挤在一起，紧张地笑着。一个穿着黑色连帽长袍、戴着骷髅面具的高大男子被指派为我们这组的导游。
There's a lot of people here. You're going to step as much to the front of the line as you can. Follow me.
这里有很多人。尽可能走到队列最前面。跟着我。
We'd line up against the back wall of the Columbine School scene, which is basically just a room with a card table stacked with books and a few school desks scattered around. Among a dozen or so student actors, two squeaky clean church girls sit at the card table, talking. Behind them, an angry demon, also dressed in a black robe and mask, paces back and forth, wringing his hands.
我们在科伦拜恩学校场景的后墙边排好队，那本质上就是一个房间，里面放着一张堆满书的折叠桌，还有几张散乱的课桌。在十几名学生演员中，两名清纯的教会女孩坐在桌旁聊天。在她们身后，一个同样穿着黑袍戴着面具的愤怒恶魔在来回踱步，两手不停揉搓。
Man, I hate this Shakespeare stuff.
天哪，我讨厌这些莎士比亚的东西。
Are you having a hard time with that? I don't know--
你在那上面遇到困难了吗？我不知道——
Their conversation about Shakespeare turns to Carrie's recent conversion to Christianity. She says she used to hate her parents and especially hated God. "I'm a Christian now," she says. "That's why I'm always so happy."
她们关于莎士比亚的谈话转到了嘉莉最近改信基督教的话题上。她说她以前讨厌父母，尤其讨厌上帝。“我现在是个基督徒了，”她说，“这就是为什么我总是这么开心。”
Yeah, I'm a Christian now. That's why I'm so happy.
是的，我现在是个基督徒了。这就是为什么我这么开心。
Well, let's see how happy you are now.
好吧，让我们看看你现在有多开心。
[SCREAMING]
（尖叫）
Two teenage boys in black trench coats explode into the room, followed by another demon. To my surprise, the boys are waving real handguns and real shotguns as they charge through the scene, kicking over tables and chairs.
两个穿着黑色风衣的青少年男孩冲进房间，后面跟着另一个恶魔。让我惊讶的是，当他们冲进场景、踢倒桌椅时，手里挥舞着真实的手枪和猎枪。
[SCREAMING]
（尖叫）
The whole scene is so violent that you forget about everything that reminds you of a bad high school play. And what makes it scary is the look of real teen angst on the shooters' faces as they cock and aim their guns at the heads of all the cowering students. You can see how they love waving around their firearms. And part of what's so shocking is you wonder, who are the good churchgoing adults who came up with this idea and helped the kids finance and organize and stage this? Remember, we're filming just six months after the real Columbine killings.
整个场景太暴力了，让你忘记了这只是糟糕的高中话剧。最可怕的是这些“枪手”脸上那种真实的青少年焦虑感，当他们扣动扳机并把枪瞄准所有畏缩的学生时。你可以看出他们有多喜欢挥舞枪支。令人震惊的一部分在于，你会想，究竟是哪些善良的信教成年人想出了这个点子，并帮助孩子们集资、组织和排演这些？记住，我们拍摄时距离真正的科伦拜恩枪击案才过了六个月。
One of the trench coat boys grabs Carrie, the Christian girl, by the hair.
其中一个穿风衣的男孩揪住了基督徒女孩嘉莉的头发。
Do you believe in God?
你相信上帝吗？
Yes.
是的。
I said, do you believe in God?
我问你，你相信上帝吗？
Yes, I believe in God.
是的，我相信上帝。
Why?
为什么？
[GUNSHOT]
（枪声）
After the boys shoot Carrie in the head, the demons perform their final task, egging the boys on to kill themselves. Then, the lights turn to strobes, the music swells, and a teenager in a white choir robe enters.
男孩们朝嘉莉头部开枪后，恶魔们执行了最终任务：怂恿男孩们自杀。然后，灯光变成频闪灯，音乐声起，一个穿着白色唱诗班长袍的青少年入场了。
It's Jesus. He's come for Carrie, the Christian girl. The shooters are dragged off to hell, kicking and screaming, and pleading to Jesus for a second chance. But he doesn't give it.
是耶稣。他来接嘉莉，那个基督徒女孩了。枪手们被拖向地狱，踢打着、尖叫着，乞求耶稣给他们第二次机会。但他没有给。
Please come back!
请回来！
Then, our tour guide reappears. He shuffles us off to the next room, the family violence scene, as another group of 40 shuffle in.
然后，我们的导游再次出现。他把我们赶向下一个房间——家庭暴力场景，而另一组40人正走进来。
Two days later, Jawad and I went home to New York and watched what we'd filmed. We were both a bit shaken up by what we had seen. I grew up in Amarillo, Texas, where one of the only ways to meet girls was to go to Christian youth meetings. And there were so many. There was Young Life and K-Life and Campus Crusade and Fellowship of Christian Athletes, not to mention that every one of the hundreds of churches had their own youth groups, hustling out to schools to compete for an ever-decreasing number of unsaved souls.
两天后，贾瓦德和我回到纽约，看了我们拍的内容。我们都被所见到的景象震住了。我在德克萨斯州的阿马里洛长大，在那里，结识女孩的唯一途径就是参加基督教青年聚会。那样的聚会有很多。有“年轻人生活”、“K-生活”、“校园十字军”和“基督教运动员团契”，更不用说成百上千个教会都有自己的青年团契，他们争先恐后地冲进学校，去争夺那些为数不多的未得救的灵魂。
I honestly thought I had heard every evangelical Christian trick in the book. But Hell House was different. The special effects, and the music, and the real guns, and the crowds and crowds of people lined up to get in, I'd never seen anything like it. So in August of 2000, we went back to Cedar Hill.
我真心以为我已经听遍了福音派基督教的所有手段。但“地狱屋”不一样。特效、音乐、真枪实弹，以及排队进入的人群，我从未见过这样的场景。所以2000年8月，我们回到了锡达希尔。
There's 30 people in the room, and you are in hell. And you're burning. So let's have some [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
房间里有30个人，你们现在身处地狱。你们正在被火烧。所以让我们来点（难以听清）。
Two months before Hell House opens each year, they have auditions at the church. The casting directors sit at a long table in front of a stage. One after another, nervous kids read for the drug dealer, the satanic worshipper, the school shooter, or the abusive father.
每年“地狱屋”开幕前两个月，他们会在教会进行试镜。选角导演坐在舞台前方的一张长桌后。紧张的孩子们一个接一个地试演毒贩、撒旦崇拜者、校园枪手或虐待成性的父亲。
It's your own fault. And what if you were pregnant? Do you really want to be your own sister's mother?
这是你自己的错。如果此时你怀孕了呢？你真的想做自己妹妹的妈妈吗？
The girls all want to be the suicide girl or the abortion girl, because those are the roles where you get to scream and cry and emote the most.
女孩们都想演自杀女孩或堕胎女孩，因为那些角色你可以尽情尖叫、哭泣和宣泄情感。
I should have gotten away from you the second that you started drinking. This is all your fault.
我就该在你开始喝酒那一刻就离你远点。这全是你的错。
[SCREAMING]
（尖叫）
Oh, wow.
噢，哇。
[INAUDIBLE].
（听不清）。
That was phenomenal.
那太出色了。
Nearly everyone wants to play a sinner. Nobody wants to play a saint. Not one person auditioned to play Jesus or an angel role. Maybe it's just more fun to be evil on stage than good. Maybe playing a churchgoing, god-fearing Christian is just not that interesting if you are a churchgoing, god-fearing Christian. The organizers usually have to go out and recruit some hapless kids to play the good Christian roles.
几乎每个人都想演罪人。没人想演圣人。没有一个人试镜耶稣或天使的角色。也许在舞台上扮演邪恶的人比扮演善良的人更有趣。也许如果你是一个虔诚的基督徒，扮演一个去教会、敬畏上帝的基督徒一点意思都没有。组织者通常不得不去招募一些倒霉的孩子来演这些善良的基督徒角色。
[CONSTRUCTION SOUNDS]
（建筑施工声）
Every day for six weeks, as many as 75 volunteers will show up to help build Hell House. It's an enormous construction site that they have to tear down and rebuild every year. There are people everywhere carrying wood, swinging hammers, and painting signs. An enthusiastic volunteer named Thad Trober took us on a quick tour during construction.
连续六周，每天都有多达75名志愿者过来帮忙搭建“地狱屋”。这是一个巨大的建筑工地，他们每年都必须拆除并重建一次。到处都是搬运木材、挥动锤子和粉刷标牌的人。一位名叫萨德·特罗伯的热情志愿者在施工期间带我们快速参观了一下。
We'll come back in here. The crucifixion is going to be right here. Coffins are going in right here. And the people who are watching are going to be looking right down in, seeing people trapped, and give them a sense of entrapment themselves. I really want to emphasize that more than anything in here, like there's absolutely no escape.
我们再进来这里。十字架受难场景就在这儿。棺材就放在这儿。参观的人会往下看，看到人们被困住，给他们一种身陷囹圄的感觉。我真的想强调这一点，比这里任何东西都重要，就是这里绝对没有逃生之路。
And then we arrive at the room that's Thad's baby.
然后我们到达了萨德负责的房间。
This is the rave-slash-suicide scene.
这是锐舞派对加自杀场景。
Thad, who wears a goatee and techno clothes, has seen what goes on in raves firsthand, the sex, the drugs, the alcohol, back in the old days, before he was a Christian. Thad told us that he'd only gone to raves to hear the music. But then it became too hard for him to ignore what was going on around him. So he had to stop raving. But now, every October, Thad gets to create his own rave at Hell House.
留着山羊胡、穿着锐舞服装的萨德，曾在成为基督徒前亲眼见过锐舞派对里的事：性、毒品、酒精。萨德告诉我们，他以前去派对只是为了听音乐。但后来他发现自己实在无法忽视周围发生的事情，所以他不得不停止去派对。但现在，每年十月，萨德都有机会在“地狱屋”里创作他自己的锐舞派对场景。
It's going to look pretty cool. Just like all the other scenes, we're going to have some plastic down each wall. But there will be a DJ, which I've played the last couple years. We'll have a makeshift turntable area. I don't know if I'll use these lights yet. I'll probably stick some black lights up, and that'll be great. And I'm actually thinking about renting a water tank. And I'll have someone underwater dance. There's something neat every year.
这看起来会很酷。就像其他场景一样，我们会在每面墙上贴上塑料膜。但会有一个DJ，过去几年都是我自己在放。我们会有个临时的唱片转盘区。我不知道这些灯光还要不要用。我大概会装一些黑光灯，那样效果会很棒。我其实在考虑租一个水箱。我会找个人在水下跳舞。每年这里都有新鲜事。
It's not within the nature of man to lose. God created us to win.
失败并非人类的天性。上帝创造我们是为了获胜。
Before Hell House opens in early October, Tim Ferguson brings everyone together for a pep talk. Tim has an intensity about him that reminds you more of a football coach than a minister. He squeezes the microphone and stares at a roomful of church kids. Behind him, three young men are noodling backup music on their electric guitars.
在“地狱屋”十月初开幕前，蒂姆·弗格森把所有人叫到一起进行励志动员。蒂姆身上有一种强烈的气场，比起牧师，他更像个足球教练。他攥着麦克风，盯着满屋子的教会孩子们。他身后，三名年轻人正用电吉他弹奏着背景音乐。
And there's a war, and there's a battle, and there's a competition. And there's a serious game where life and death is at stake. It's not just you lose and you go home. We're competing for lost souls. And we're going to win. We're in this to win. We're not in this just to go through it, just for something else to do. I don't need something else to do. OK?
这是一场战争，是一场战斗，是一场竞争。这是一场关乎生死的严肃比赛。不仅仅是输了就回家。我们是在为失落的灵魂竞争。我们要赢。我们是为赢而战的。我们来这里不是为了走个过场，只是为了找点事做。我不需要找别的事做。明白吗？
And just when everyone's getting really worked up, they start speaking in tongues. Trinity Church is an Assembly of God church, which is a branch of the Pentecostals. Pentecostals are known as the church that speaks in tongues, and they're the fastest-growing Christian church in the world. They started less than 100 years ago in Los Angeles. And they've always been able to put on a good production for large audiences. They were the first church to use electric guitars, one of the first to break into TV evangelism, and the first to think up Hell House.
就在每个人情绪高涨时，他们开始说起方言。三一教会是一个神召会教会，这是五旬节派的一个分支。五旬节派以说方言著称，是世界上增长最快的基督教派。他们不到100年前始于洛杉矶。他们总是能为大规模观众提供精彩的表演。他们是第一批使用电吉他的教会，最早突破电视传教限制的教会之一，也是第一个想出“地狱屋”创意的教会。
Hundreds of teenagers are lined up to go into Hell House. It's a pretty diverse crowd, large groups of Hispanic and African-American kids mixed in with the suburban white crowd, all paying $7 each for a ticket. It looks to be the same demographic as at Six Flags. But in fact, most of these kids have been bused here by youth leaders from the area.
成百上千的青少年排队进入“地狱屋”。这是一群相当多元化的观众，大批西班牙裔和非裔美国孩子与郊区的白人孩子混在一起，每人都花了7美元买票。这看起来和六旗乐园的客群差不多。但事实上，这些孩子大多是由当地的青年导师用大巴运来的。
Once they get inside, they see kids committing suicide, being killed by drunk drivers, and being sacrificed to the devil. In the hospital scene, the abortion girl sits in a pool of fake blood. She's wearing white sweat pants, and her crotch is completely soaked in red. Next to her, a gay teenager dies over and over from AIDS. He dies every 7 to 10 minutes, every night, for three weeks straight.
一旦进入室内，他们会看到孩子们自杀、被酒驾司机撞死，以及被献祭给魔鬼。在医院场景中，堕胎女孩坐在血泊中。她穿着白色运动裤，胯部完全被红色浸透了。在她旁边，一个同性恋青少年不断地死于艾滋病。他每晚每7到10分钟死一次，连续三周。
This is Steve. He thought his homosexual lifestyle was everything a real man could want. But now, he's dying of AIDS.
这是史蒂夫。他曾以为他的同性恋生活方式是一个男人想要的一切。但现在，他正死于艾滋病。
Steve, I'm right here. I'm not going to leave.
史蒂夫，我就在这里。我不会走的。
Why does this happen to me? Why can't it just be over?
为什么这会发生在我身上？为什么这一切不能结束？
Outside the house, in an area visitors don't have access to, I ran into a group of performers that had just knocked off from their shift at being tortured in hell. It's obvious they've been having a good time. I asked them what was the most fun scene in Hell House.
在屋子外面，在一个参观者无法进入的区域，我遇到了刚结束轮班、从地狱折磨中撤下来的表演者。很明显他们玩得很开心。我问他们“地狱屋”里最好玩的是哪个场景。
School shooting.
校园枪击。
Yeah, school shooting's the best.
是的，校园枪击最棒了。
No, it's not.
不，不是。
Yes it is.
就是。
It's the rave.
是锐舞派对。
The rave scene's the best, because you get to dance.
锐舞派对场景最棒，因为你可以跳舞。
Hey, what's up? What's your name?
嘿，怎么了？你叫什么名字？
I'm Jessica.
我是杰西卡。
Jessica, I'm Chad.
杰西卡，我是查德。
Even though you get to dance, the rave scene does not end well. The girl in it sips her spiked drink, freaks out, gets gang-raped, and ends up killing herself, after admitting that her dad had molested her as a child.
即使可以跳舞，锐舞派对场景的结局也不好。派对上的女孩喝了掺了料的酒，陷入疯狂，被轮奸，最后在承认父亲童年曾猥亵过她后选择了自杀。
How do you like it?
你觉得怎么样？
Whoo.
喔。
Good stuff, isn't it?
好东西，不是吗？
So once a group of visitors makes it all the way through the gory scenes, they come to what is called the "decision room."
所以，当一群参观者走完全程的血腥场景后，他们会来到所谓的“决定室”。
How y'all doing? Can I get you to line up over here, please? Yeah, straight line as possible. OK, as you saw in each scene, someone died. They went to either heaven or hell. If you were to die tonight, do you know where you will go? Or do you think that you know? If this is you, I want to ask you to step through the door. There are people in the next room waiting to pray with you now. You've got six seconds. Five seconds.
大家好吗？请在这边排好队，好吗？尽可能排成直线。好的，正如你们在每个场景中看到的，有人死了。他们要么去了天堂，要么下了地狱。如果你今晚死去，你知道你会去哪里吗？或者你觉得你知道吗？如果是你，我想请你穿过那扇门。隔壁房间有人正在等候和你一起祈祷。给你六秒钟时间。五秒钟。
Of the 40 people in this group, about 10 go to pray with the counselors. The 30 others are held back a minute, and then they're marched to the exit. But it turns out that the damned have to exit through the same door as the saved. There's only one exit, and it's on the other side of the room of crying and praying Christians and counselors. The 30 shuffle through guiltily, with their heads down, trying not to catch anyone's eye.
这组40人中，约有10人去和辅导员祈祷。其他30人被拦住了一分钟，然后被引导走向出口。但结果证明，被诅咒的人必须和被拯救的人从同一个门离开。这里只有一个出口，就在满屋子哭泣祈祷的基督徒和辅导员的另一侧。这30个人羞愧地低着头鱼贯而出，尽量避免和任何人对视。
Do you believe in God?
你相信上帝吗？
About 13,000 people went through Hell House this year alone. Trinity Church claims that as many as one out of five people that go through Hell House become Christians or recommit themselves to the church.
今年仅“地狱屋”就有大约13,000人参观。三一教会声称，多达五分之一参观过“地狱屋”的人成为了基督徒或重新投身于教会。
When we die, we can go to heaven and be with Jesus. It's so awesome. It's radical, yeah.
当我们死后，我们可以去天堂和耶稣在一起。太棒了。真激进，是吧。
If you ask the teenagers at Hell House straight up if they have fun pretending to shoot their classmates or do drugs at a rave, they're all good Christian kids and know better than to admit that they enjoyed themselves. "Our goal is to save souls and make money for the church," they'll tell you. And they'll mean it. But Hell House is the biggest event of the year for Trinity Church.
如果你直接问“地狱屋”里的青少年，假装射杀同学或在派对上吸毒是否有趣，他们都是虔诚的基督徒，明白不能承认自己享受其中。“我们的目标是拯救灵魂并为教会筹款，”他们会告诉你。而且他们是真心的。“地狱屋”是三一教会每年最大的活动。
After three weeks of performances, after Halloween comes and goes, the kids all get dressed up to the nines for an event that is the equivalent of prom night for them. They call it the Hell House Oscars. On stage at a podium, in front of a table of Oscar-like trophies, presenters banter and give awards for best tour guide, best abortion girl, best drunk driver, best gremlin, and best archangel. Remember, three to six teenagers play each part in the house.
三周表演结束后，万圣节过了，孩子们会盛装打扮参加一个对他们来说相当于毕业舞会的活动。他们称之为“地狱屋奥斯卡”。在舞台讲台上，面对着一桌类似奥斯卡的奖杯，主持人开着玩笑，颁发最佳导游奖、最佳堕胎女孩奖、最佳醉酒司机奖、最佳小恶魔奖和最佳大天使奖。请记住，在屋子里每个角色都有三到六名青少年饰演。
This year's suicide award goes to Liz Simmons! Come on out.
今年的自杀奖得主是——利兹·西蒙斯！出来吧。
Liz Simmons, in a floor-length gown, pluckily hops out of her seat, hugging friends, waving to photographers, and makes her way to the stage.
穿着及地长裙的利兹·西蒙斯活泼地跳下座位，拥抱朋友，向摄影师挥手，走向舞台。
Well, I couldn't have done it without my rapers, so thank you, Brent and David. And I just want to say, it was really an honor to do this part. At first, I was real uncomfortable with it, you know, when I heard that I was going to have to be raped. And I was like, OK, what's that going to be like? But it ended up being a lot of fun, and--
好吧，没有我的强奸犯们我可做不到，所以谢谢布伦特和戴维。我只想说，扮演这个角色真的是一种荣幸。起初，我对此感到非常不舒服，你知道，当我听说我将不得不被强奸时。我当时想，好吧，那会是什么样？但结果发现这真的很有趣，而且——
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
OK, wait, I didn't say that right. No, I just really got to meet a lot of people that I didn't know, and I had a-- OK, this is only getting worse.
好吧，等等，我没说对。不，我只是真的认识了许多我不认识的人，而且我有一个——好吧，这真是越描越黑了。
She lifts her fake Oscar and walks off stage. In the dozen years since Trinity Church invented Hell House, the idea has spread all over the country. No one knows how many Hell Houses are out there now, but a church in Colorado has sold over 500 Hell House franchise kits with layout designs, scripts, and a video, for $200 each.
她举起那个假奥斯卡奖杯走下舞台。在三一教会发明“地狱屋”的十几年里，这个创意传遍了全国。没人知道现在有多少个“地狱屋”，但科罗拉多州的一家教会已经以每个200美元的价格售出了超过500套“地狱屋”加盟套件，其中包括布局设计、剧本和录像带。
Let's give a big hand to Mr. Jonathan Parker, the winner of the school violence director's award.
让我们用热烈的掌声欢迎校园暴力导演奖得主——乔纳森·帕克先生。
These church kids aren't supposed to drink. They aren't supposed to party or sleep together. But tonight, they glitter like sinners. Unlike the real Oscars, no one complains that this ceremony lasts too long.
这些教会的孩子是不被允许喝酒的。他们不准聚会或同居。但今晚，他们却闪耀得如同罪人。与真正的奥斯卡不同，没人抱怨这场颁奖礼太长。
I had a great time with all of my suicide girls. I got to act with every single one of you almost every night.
我和我所有的“自杀女孩”们度过了一段美好的时光。几乎每天晚上我都有机会和你们中的每一个演对手戏。
George Ratliff, you can find his movie Hell House online at hellhousemovie.com. The church George mentions in Colorado has now sold over 800 Hell House starter kits to churches in every state and in 24 countries, as well as to secular theater companies in New York and Los Angeles. In Los Angeles, Bill Maher played the devil.
乔治·拉特利夫，你可以在hellhousemovie.com网站上找到他的电影《地狱屋》。乔治提到的科罗拉多州的那个教会，现在已经向全美各州和24个国家的教会，以及纽约和洛杉矶的商业剧团售出了超过800套“地狱屋”入门套件。在洛杉矶，比尔·马赫还扮演过魔鬼。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "THE DEVIL WENT DOWN TO GEORGIA" BY THE CHARLIE DANIELS BAND]
（音乐播放 - 查理·丹尼尔斯乐队的《魔鬼下到乔治亚》）
Act Two, Sixteen Candles Can Lead to a Lot of Fire. Faron Yoder lives in Amish country, in Indiana. And I interviewed him from his parents' house, where he lives. For this to happen, somebody had to go there with a cell phone.
第二幕，十六岁蜡烛可能引发大火。法伦·约德住在印第安纳州的阿米什人地区。我在他居住的父母家中采访了他。为了实现这次采访，得有人带一部手机去那里。
And he talked to me from his room. I was in our radio studio. Faron lives differently from everybody in his family. And his room is different from the rest of the house.
他从他的房间里跟我对话。当时我在我们的广播工作室。法伦的生活方式与他家里所有人都不同。他的房间也与房子的其他部分截然不同。
The rest of the house is very Amish. Well, the whole house is actually very Amish, no electricity, gas lighting. In my room, I've got a TV. I've got a stereo. I've got a PlayStation 2. A lot of my friends come over here. We play PlayStation and just hang out, drink beer.
房子的其他部分非常有阿米什特色。好吧，其实整栋房子都很有阿米什风格，没有电，用煤气灯。但在我的房间里，我有电视。我有音响。我有PlayStation 2。我的很多朋友常来这里。我们玩PlayStation，闲逛，喝啤酒。
How do you have electricity if the rest of the house doesn't?
如果房子的其他地方没电，你是怎么弄到电的？
Well, actually, I've got an electrical cord. This is kind of funny, probably. But I've got an electrical cord that runs up to my TV and to everything. And then I've got it going out my window. And I run the cord out to my car. And so I just go out , start up the car, and plug in the electrical cord. And I spend the whole night up here and don't have to worry about it.
嗯，其实我有一根电线。这可能听起来有点好笑。但我有一根电线接到我的电视和所有设备上。然后我把它从窗户牵出去。我把电线接到我的车上。所以我就出门，启动车子，插上电源。我就整晚待在上面，不用担心没电。
We heard about Faron through a movie called Devil's Playground, which is about the Amish rite of rumspringa. Rumspringa has been in the news a bit lately, partly, I think, because all of us regular Americans like stories where the Amish sink as low as we do. In case you've never heard of it, rumspringa works like this. At 16, Amish teenagers are told they can drive, they can drink, they can use modern electronics. They can try all the things the outside world has to offer. And then, after a few years, at 19 or 20 or 21, they will be in a position to decide what they want to do with their lives.
我们是通过一部名为《魔鬼的操场》的电影听说法伦的，这部电影讲述的是阿米什人的“浪荡期”仪式。浪荡期最近成了新闻话题，我觉得部分原因是像我们这样的普通美国人喜欢看阿米什人像我们一样堕落的故事。如果你没听说过，浪荡期是这样的：到了16岁，阿米什青少年被告知他们可以开车、可以喝酒、可以使用现代电子产品。他们可以尝试外界所能提供的一切。然后，几年后，到了19岁、20岁或21岁，他们将能决定自己想要什么样的人生。
If they want to live like regular Americans, they are free to go. If they want to commit to the church and the Amish way of life, they get baptized. And they're expected to stay in the Amish community until they die. In short, they're asked to make a decision that most of us make gradually every day about how we're going to live our lives in these few years, when they're teenagers.
如果他们想过普通美国人的生活，他们可以自由离开。如果他们想投身教会和阿米什人的生活方式，他们就接受洗礼。他们被期望留在阿米什社区直到去世。简而言之，他们被要求在十几岁那几年里，做出我们大多数人每天都在一点点做出的决定——我们要如何过我们的一生。
Faron is 21, and after his rumspringa, he has not chosen the church. During that time, as the film Devil's Playground shows, he got into a lot of trouble. Not only did he develop a $100-a-day crystal meth habit, he sold drugs. He got in trouble with the law. Right now, he's facing 14 months in prison for all that. He says that before he turned 16, back before his rumspringa began, he had a whole list of things that he knew he wanted to do.
法伦今年21岁，浪荡期结束后，他没有选择教会。在那段时间里，正如电影《魔鬼的操场》所展示的，他惹了很多麻烦。他不仅养成了每天100美元的冰毒习惯，还贩卖毒品。他惹上了官司。目前，他因为那些事情面临14个月的监禁。他说在16岁之前，在浪荡期开始前，他有一张清单，上面全是他知道自己想做的事情。
I wanted, well, pretty much everything. I just wanted to be a normal kid and have a normal life. Everybody else was coming to school with Walkmans and going home and playing PlayStation. It was just everything, from going shopping to just-- I was envious of everything that everybody else had.
我想要，嗯，差不多一切吧。我只是想成为一个普通孩子，过正常的生活。其他人都带着随身听去学校，回家玩PlayStation。从去购物到——我嫉妒所有人拥有的一切。
When you're sheltered all your life, you consider pretty much everybody else as, "Aw, man. They're lucky as hell, because they've got all this stuff." And I just wanted to have that. I wanted to be that.
当你一辈子都被呵护时，你差不多会认为其他人是“天哪，他们太幸运了，因为他们有这么多东西。”我只是想拥有这些。我想成为那样的人。
What was the first thing you did on the first day after you turned 16, and you had the freedom to do what you wanted?
你16岁生日后的第一天，拥有了随心所欲的自由，你做的第一件事是什么？
On the first day, I went and got rid of my Amish haircut, went and got rid of my Amish clothes, bought regular clothes. And it was a Friday or Saturday night. It was on a weekend. And I got drunk and just, I thought I was the coolest thing in the world.
第一天，我去剪掉了我的阿米什发型，扔掉了我的阿米什衣服，买了普通衣服。那天是个周五或周六晚上。是在周末。我喝醉了，我觉得自己简直是世界上最酷的人。
One of the teenage girls in the movie, Velda, says, "God talks to me in one ear, Satan in the other. Part of me wants to be like my parents, but the other part wants the jeans, the haircut, to do what I want." Is that your experience, too? Or was it your experience, this feeling of, OK, God's in one ear, and Satan is in the other?
电影里的一位十几岁女孩维尔达说：“上帝在我一只耳朵里说话，撒旦在另一只耳朵里。一部分我想像父母那样，但另一部分想要牛仔裤、发型，想做我想做的事。”这是你的经历吗？还是说，你有那种“好吧，上帝在这一只耳朵，撒旦在那一只耳朵”的感觉？
Well, actually, I ignored God for a long time. And for a long time, I told everybody that I was atheist. I think I've really searched a lot and struggled to listen to God.
嗯，其实我很久都没理过上帝。很长一段时间里，我都告诉别人我是无神论者。我想我确实寻找了很久，努力去倾听上帝。
And was there any part of you where you were afraid that if you didn't return to the Amish lifestyle, that you would be punished, that you would go to hell?
有没有那么一部分你，担心如果不回到阿米什人的生活方式，你会受到惩罚，你会下地狱？
Yeah, definitely. There was always that fear. And there still is sometimes. I guess not anymore, but there used to be, until just lately. It was always at the back of my mind, always nagging me.
是的，绝对有。那种恐惧一直存在。甚至现在有时还有。我想现在没有了，但以前确实有，直到最近才消失。它一直在我脑海深处，一直折磨着我。
There was this fear that, hey, you're going to hell, because you're not living a Christian life, and you're not Amish. I don't know. It was just, I don't feel that one has to be Amish to get into heaven, of course, but I feel that that is probably the easiest way, or one of the easiest ways to attain that.
那种恐惧在于，嘿，你要下地狱了，因为你没有过基督徒的生活，你也不是阿米什人。我不知道。只是，我并不觉得一个人非得是阿米什人才能上天堂，当然，但我感觉那可能是最容易的方法，或者说实现这个目标的最容易的方法之一。
Do you think hell exists?
你认为地狱存在吗？
According to the Bible, yes.
根据《圣经》，是的。
And do you believe it?
你相信吗？
I don't know exactly what I believe right now.
我现在不知道自己确切相信什么。
We're doing another story in this week's radio show about these teenagers outside Dallas. And there's a church youth group that they're part of that does something called a Hell House, where every Halloween, they stage all the ways that somebody can end up in hell. And the idea is to scare people so bad, and young people especially, that they'll never try anything.
我们本周的广播节目里还有另一个故事，关于达拉斯外的一群青少年。他们参与的教会青年团契做了一件叫“地狱屋”的事情，每年万圣节，他们都会重演所有会导致人下地狱的方式。这个想法是想把人们吓得半死，特别是年轻人，这样他们就永远不会去尝试任何事。
They'll never try to drink. They'll never try to do drugs. They'll never try to do anything bad.
他们永远不会尝试喝酒。他们永远不会尝试吸毒。他们永远不会尝试做任何坏事。
And the idea of this church group is that that will bring teenagers to God. And you were raised with exactly the opposite philosophy, where, once you become a teenager, the church elders are saying to you, "OK, go out. Try everything, and then you'll discover actually choosing God is the right choice." Which do you think might be better?
这个教会团体的初衷是，那样会把青少年带到上帝面前。而你成长的哲学恰恰相反，当你有机会成为青少年时，教会长辈对你说：“好吧，出去吧。尝试一切，然后你就会发现选择上帝才是正确的选择。”你认为哪种更好？
I think the Amish approach is definitely better. Whereas in the Hell House there, I feel that you should be scared of God, yes, but that shouldn't be the reason that you follow Jesus. One should make that choice because he wants to and he feels that that's the best way to live, not just because, oh, I'll go to hell if I don't.
我觉得阿米什人的做法肯定更好。至于那个“地狱屋”，我觉得你应该敬畏上帝，是的，但这不应该是你追随耶稣的理由。一个人应该是因为他想追随，并且觉得那是最好的生活方式而做出选择，而不是因为“哦，我不这么做就会下地狱”。
Do you think it's an advantage to their way to try to protect their kids? I think there are people all over this country who are trying to protect their kids from all the bad things that your elders sort of pushed you towards, partying, and you know.
你觉得保护他们的孩子对他们来说是一种优势吗？我想全国各地都有人试图保护他们的孩子免受你长辈推向你的那些坏事影响，比如聚会，你知道的。
I don't know. But just my own opinion, I think it will do more harm than good.
我不知道。但就我个人意见，我觉得那会弊大于利。
Why?
为什么？
Well, just for myself, if somebody tells me, "Hey, you can't do this, or you're going to get punished," I'm going to say, "Watch me get away with it."
嗯，就我而言，如果有人告诉我：“嘿，你不能做这个，否则你会受惩罚，”我会说：“看我怎么钻空子逃掉。”
I wondered, are the church elders in your church counting on the fact that, when you go out and you see what the rest of the world is like, it won't seem so great?
我在想，你们教会的长辈是否指望你出去看到外面的世界是什么样之后，会觉得外面也就那样？
Well, yeah, I think that's kind of the point. Because you get out, and you see that there are so many unhappy people in the world. And I'm not saying that there aren't any unhappy Amish people. But still, I think the larger percentage of Amish people, really happy and content with what they have, even if they don't have that much. I think in the film it says something, about 85% of Amish kids go back to the Amish way of life.
嗯，是的，我觉得那也是目的所在。因为你走出去，看到世界上有那么多不幸的人。我不是说没有不幸的阿米什人。但我觉得，阿米什人中绝大多数人对他们所拥有的感到真正快乐和满足，即使他们并没有拥有那么多东西。我想电影里说了，大约85%的阿米什孩子会回到阿米什人的生活方式。
90%, they said.
他们说是90%。
90%. OK. Most people go back. Because really, the Amish way of life is an attractive lifestyle. You don't have all the modern things, or whatever, but as far as peace, tranquility, and have a calm life, it's beautiful.
90%。好吧。大多数人都回去了。因为实际上，阿米什人的生活方式是一种很有吸引力的生活方式。你没有所有的现代东西，或者其他的什么，但就安宁、平静和平静的生活而言，那是很美好的。
90% of the people go back. And so how are you different?
90%的人都回去了。那你为什么不一样？
Well, I got into drugs. And I, well, just to tell the truth, I lost most of my Amish friends, and had to go out and find others.
嗯，我染上了毒品。而且，嗯，说实话，我失去了大部分阿米什朋友，不得不出去寻找其他人。
Yeah. Oh, I see. So you actually had to make a life outside of the Amish community. So then it was easier just to stay out.
是的。噢，我明白了。所以你实际上必须在阿米什社区之外建立生活。所以那样的话，继续待在外面就更容易了。
Yeah, yeah, absolutely. Once you have a life outside the Amish community, it's kind of hard to get back in.
是的，是的，绝对是。一旦你在阿米什社区之外有了生活，就很难回去了。
How are you doing? Are you as happy, do you think, as your friends who went back to the Amish way of life?
你现在过得怎么样？你觉得你像那些回到阿米什生活方式的朋友一样快乐吗？
I think so. I'm-- I don't know. I always have a-- I don't know about happy. I'm just more relaxed now.
我想是的。我——我不知道。我总是有一个——我不确定是不是快乐。我现在只是更放松了。
And do you have moments where you actually find yourself still wondering, "Oh, I wonder if I would have been better off if I had gone back"?
你有没有过这样的时刻：你发现自己依然在想，“哦，我想知道如果我回去了，会不会过得更好”？
Yeah, yeah, I do. Not very often, but there are times. I wonder where I'd be, or who I'd be, if I would have made the choice just to stay Amish and be this responsible young man.
有的，有的，确实有。虽然不常有，但确实有那么些时候。我好奇如果我选择了留在阿米什社区，做那个负责任的年轻人，我现在会在哪里，或者会成为什么样的人。
Faron Yoder, the film he's in is called Devil's Playground. You can find copies of it online. Coming up, if you do good, but you do not remember it, and maybe you did not even intend to do good in the first place, does it count? That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
法伦·约德，他参演的电影叫《魔鬼的操场》。你可以在网上找到它的拷贝。接下来，如果你做了善事，但你不记得了，而且也许你根本没打算做善事，这算数吗？那一分钟之后，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际公司，当我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Devil on My Shoulder, stories of people who believe that the Devil is talking in their ear, and of people who deny that, despite massive evidence to the contrary.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，“肩上的魔鬼”，讲述那些相信魔鬼在耳边私语的人的故事，以及那些否认这一点——尽管有大量反面证据存在的人的故事。
We have arrived at Act Three of our program, Act Three, Devil in Angel's Clothing, Or Is It the Other Way Around? This is the story of what it means to have a conscience. A man kills another man on the street and then tries to pretend that it never happened for 20 years. And it's a story about what that does to him. Sarah Koenig reports from Baltimore.
我们已经到达了节目的第三幕，“天使外衣下的魔鬼，还是恰恰相反？”这是关于“良知”意味着什么的故事。一个男人在街上杀死了另一个人，然后试图假装这件事从未发生，过了20年。这是一个关于那件事对他造成什么影响的故事。萨拉·科尼格从巴尔的摩报道。
Sterling Randolph Willis told me his story over the phone from prison. As you'll hear, the phone line is terrible, but it was the only way to get him on tape. The prison doesn't allow recording equipment inside the facility.
斯特林·伦道夫·威利斯在监狱里通过电话告诉了我他的故事。你会听到，电话线路非常糟糕，但这是录下他声音的唯一方法。监狱不允许在设施内使用录音设备。
When he was 17 years old, Randy lived with his mother and did construction work. He'd been kicked out of school for fighting. He was tall and quiet. And like a lot of kids from his neighborhood, he carried a serious knife.
兰迪17岁那年，和母亲住在一起，做建筑工。他因为打架被学校开除了。他长得很高，沉默寡言。像他那个街区的许多孩子一样，他随身带着一把锋利的刀。
His girlfriend, who was 16, lived miles across town, and Randy liked to walk to her house, rather than take the bus or a cab. It gave him time to be alone, he says, and to think about things. He was on his way there on Christmas night in 1982. He cut through a back way in the dark and stopped at some bushes to pee.
他的女朋友16岁，住在城另一头，相隔好几英里，兰迪喜欢步行去她家，而不是坐公交车或打车。他说，这给了他时间独处，思考一些事情。1982年的圣诞之夜，他正在去她家的路上。他在黑暗中抄了一条小路，停在一些灌木丛边撒尿。
I saw this guy coming towards me. And I was like, "What do you want?" And he was mumbling something. I didn't know what he was saying.
我看到这个家伙朝我走来。我说：“你想干什么？”他在嘟囔些什么。我不知道他在说什么。
And I saw him rubbing on the front of his pants. And I tell him, "Stop, back away from me." And he's still coming towards me.
我看到他揉着自己的裤子前部。我告诉他：“停下，离我远点。”他还是一直朝我走来。
And he's mumbling and giggling. He's looking like, "Aha, I got one." That scared me a bit.
他在嘟囔着，还在傻笑。他那样子好像在说：“哈哈，我抓到一个了。”这让我有点害怕。
And when he came close to me again, I hit him. And when I hit him, he fell back. That's when I jumped on him. And that's when I stabbed him.
当他再次靠近我时，我打了他。我打他时，他向后倒下。就在那时我扑向他。就在那时我捅了他。
He didn't know whether the guy was dead or alive. He just took off running to his girlfriend's house.
他不知道那家伙是死是活。他只是拔腿跑向他女朋友家。
I went in the back doorway, because I knew that my girlfriend would be in the kitchen waiting for me to get there. Because she really wasn't a party person, either. I had a little blood on me. I washed it off.
我从后门进去了，因为我知道女朋友会在厨房里等我过去。因为她也不是个喜欢派对的人。我身上带了点血。我把它洗掉了。
And I was really shooken up. It took about a half an hour before I could tell her what happened. And she thought I was joking around at first.
我真的被吓坏了。我花了大约半小时才敢告诉她发生了什么。起初她以为我在开玩笑。
Randy had killed Arnette Hubbard, a 44-year-old man who had no fixed address. Police had a hard time notifying his relatives. His wallet revealed to detectives that he was a military veteran.
兰迪杀死了阿内特·哈伯德，一个44岁、居无定所的男人。警方很难通知到他的亲属。他的钱包向警探透露了他曾是一名退伍军人。
Did the detectives ever question you, or question anyone you had told?
警探有没有盘问过你，或者盘问过任何你告诉过这件事的人？
They didn't question me, because I didn't live around there. I didn't go back around there for a little while. I was really, really scared. You could see it in my face that I was pretty much terrified. I didn't want the police looking at me like "Oh, look at him, he [UNINTELLIGIBLE] guilty." Because a couple of questions, and I would have been like putty in their hands.
他们没有盘问我，因为我不住在那附近。我有段时间没去过那附近了。我真的，非常害怕。你从我脸上就能看出我几乎被吓破胆了。我不想让警察看着我就像在说：“哦，看那家伙，他（听不清）有罪。”因为只要问几个问题，我就会像他们手里的一团烂泥。
Eventually, Hubbard's murder fell into the department's cold case files. In that sense, Randy had gotten away with it. But in his mind, he carried the stabbing with him.
最终，哈伯德的谋杀案成了部门的冷案档案。从某种意义上说，兰迪逃脱了惩罚。但在他心里，他带着那次捅人的经历。
Different times throughout my life, over the years, I've had nightmares about it. One time, he pulled me in the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] in my dream. And he was shaking me, laughing real hard. And I woke up screaming out of my sleep. And sometimes, I would see it happen all over again, like on the wall, just like a film projector, like a dream, only wide awake.
多年来，在不同时期，我都会做关于它的噩梦。有一次，他在梦里把我拉进（听不清）。他在摇晃我，笑得特别大声。我从梦中尖叫着醒来。有时，我会再次看到那一幕，就像在墙上放电影，就像梦境，只是我完全清醒。
Randy felt guilty about what happened, and says that if he had to do it over again, he wouldn't have killed Arnette Hubbard. But he didn't feel that guilty. He was molested as a child, he says, and he thinks the guy he killed was a pervert waiting for a victim. What if someone else had taken that shortcut, a girl who couldn't protect herself, say?
兰迪对自己做过的事感到内疚，并说如果能重来一次，他不会杀阿内特·哈伯德。但他并没有那么内疚。他说他童年受过猥亵，他觉得他杀的那个人是个等待受害者的变态。如果换作别人走了那条捷径，比如一个无法自卫的女孩呢？
After the stabbing, Randy tried to get on with his life. He and his girlfriend got married. He worked at different jobs, and they started having children. But he was still tormented by that night.
那次捅人之后，兰迪试图继续生活。他和女朋友结婚了。他干过不同的工作，他们开始有了孩子。但他仍然被那个夜晚折磨。
He would break out crying sometimes. He was terrified people would find out what he had done. The scene would play over and over in his mind. He went to psychiatrists, who gave him medication, but he never confessed the source of his anxiety. Pretty soon, he started taking harder drugs, mostly heroin.
他有时会突然哭出来。他很害怕别人发现他做过的事。那一幕在他脑海中反复重现。他去看过心理医生，吃过药，但他从没承认过焦虑的根源。没过多久，他开始吸食更强的毒品，主要是海洛因。
When I told my wife about it, she was disappointed in me. I told her that I was getting high. I needed her help to stop.
当我告诉妻子这件事时，她对我感到很失望。我告诉她我吸毒了。我需要她的帮助戒毒。
I just couldn't figure out at that point what move to make in my life. I didn't want to be high. I didn't want the medication. I wanted the dreams to stop, the visions I was having. I wanted that all to just go away.
我当时简直想不出生活中该迈出哪一步。我不想吸毒。我不想吃药。我只想让那些噩梦停下来，那些我看到的幻象。我只想让这一切都烟消云散。
While he was going through all this, his wife was changing. She had found the church and become passionate about it. Randy wasn't interested.
在他经历这一切的同时，他的妻子也在改变。她找到了教会，并对此充满热情。兰迪毫无兴趣。
I'd usually just basically turn on The Three Stooges on Sunday and sit back and, you know, laughing at the TV. And by that time, my wife was already in church. And she'd just run around the house, "Hallelujah, hallelujah."
我通常会在周日打开电视看《三个臭皮匠》，然后坐在后面，你知道的，嘲笑电视上的内容。到那时，我妻子已经在教会了。她会在屋子里跑来跑去：“哈利路亚，哈利路亚。”
I thought, to me, this is funny, right? Because I'd never seen this side of her. I thought it was hilarious.
我当时心想，这真可笑，对吧？因为我从来没见过她这一面。我觉得这滑稽透了。
I didn't take it seriously until we had a little sit-down about it one day. And I knew she was serious, then, because she was welling up with tears. And I really felt bad. So that made me want to start going, see what this Jesus thing was all about.
直到有一天我们为此坐下来谈过，我才把它当回事。我知道她是认真的，因为她泪流满面。我真的感到很难过。所以这让我想要开始去（教会），看看这“耶稣”到底是怎么回事。
And the first time I went, I basically didn't stay for the whole service, because it made me feel kind of strange. I wasn't used to being in contact with my emotions like that. And I'm sitting, and I'm feeling my eyes well up with tears, and my heart is bumping kind of fast. I feel butterflies in my stomach. And this is not a feeling that I like.
第一次去的时候，我基本没待到礼拜结束，因为它让我感觉有点奇怪。我不习惯那样接触自己的情感。我坐着，感到眼眶湿润，心跳加速。我感到肚子里有蝴蝶乱飞。这不是我喜欢的感触。
So I left. I waited outside. I didn't tell her the truth about how I felt. The truth was, I just couldn't handle it. I just couldn't sit there through the whole thing. I felt like everything the preacher was saying was stabbing me right in the heart. It was like he was directing it right to me.
所以我离开了。我在外面等。我没告诉她我真正的感觉。真相是，我根本承受不了。我就是没法坐在那里听完。我觉得牧师说的每一句话都像是在刺我的心。就像他是在针对我一样。
Do you remember what he was saying? Like, what were the things that he was saying that you felt were directed at you?
你记得他说什么吗？比如，他说了哪些让你觉得是在针对你的话？
You know, sin and you're going to hell. And once you come to the Lord, you bring all your kids, and start your life on the path of righteousness. I'm like, "What, did somebody tell him about me or something?" Because every time I turn around, he's saying the stuff, and he's looking right at me. And I'm like, maybe somebody has been talking about me or something.
你知道的，罪恶，你会下地狱。一旦你投靠上帝，你就会带上你的孩子，走上正义之路。我心想：“什么，有人告诉他关于我的事了吗？”因为我每次转过头，他都在说这些，而且还直勾勾地看着我。我心想，也许有人一直在谈论我，或者怎么着。
Randy was so bothered by what happened that on his third trip to church, he did something sort of crazy. He actually decided to rob the place during the service. He didn't so much want the money, he said. He just wanted to control the people who were making him feel so strangely. He tucked a gun in the waistband of his pants and waited for the moment he could grab the collection plate. But a deacon figured out Randy's plan and confronted him.
兰迪对发生的事感到非常困扰，以至于在第三次去教会时，他做了一件疯狂的事。他竟然决定在礼拜期间抢劫教堂。他说，他并不是那么想要钱。他只是想控制那些让他感到奇怪的人。他把枪插进裤腰，等待着夺取奉献盘的时刻。但一位执事看穿了兰迪的计划，并质问他。
He leaned over my head while he was praying. And he was like, "Just give it to me. Give me the gun, son. You're not going to hurt anybody, and nobody knows what you want to do.
他趁我祈祷时俯下身子，他说：“把它给我。把枪给我，孩子。你不会伤害任何人，没人知道你想做什么。”
So I had a warm feeling of emotions flushing over me. And all of a sudden, I started crying and whatnot. My nose is running. I'm falling all out on the floor.
所以一种温暖的感受涌上心头。突然间，我开始哭泣什么的。我的鼻子在流涕。我瘫倒在地板上。
When I came to, I didn't have the gun on me anymore. My wife is crying and clapping and whatnot. My kids are looking at me like, "What's the matter with Dad?" That's what really started my walk in the church.
当我清醒过来时，身上已经没枪了。我妻子在哭泣、拍手什么的。我的孩子们看着我，像在问：“爸爸怎么了？”那才是我真正开始走入教会的起点。
He started attending regularly. He opened up services by leading songs, assisted the ministers, and eventually became president of the church's Brotherhood Association. The church even made him lose his craving for drugs, he says. He quit cold, and stayed sober for about eight years.
他开始定期参加礼拜。他带头领唱，协助牧师，最终成为了教会“兄弟协会”的会长。他说，教会甚至让他戒掉了对毒品的渴求。他突然彻底戒掉，并保持了八年清醒。
He describes that time as good and clean, among the best years of his life. He started his own landscaping business called Sterling Service. His brother-in-law was one of the church leaders, and they became close.
他形容那段时光是美好而纯净的，是他生命中最美好的岁月。他开了自己的园艺公司，叫“斯特林服务”。他的姐夫是教会领袖之一，他们走得很近。
As Randy began to worry about his own salvation, he actually told him and a church deacon about murdering Arnette Hubbard. They said he'd be forgiven, which relieved him. The visions and nightmares eased, and he appeared to be conquering his past.
随着兰迪开始担心自己的救赎，他其实告诉过姐夫和一位教会执事关于谋杀阿内特·哈伯德的事。他们说他会被原谅，这让他宽心了。那些幻象和噩梦减少了，他似乎正在征服他的过去。
But toward the end of that period, his father died. Then he lost a lot of his landscaping equipment in a fire. Winter came, and his clients fell away. He needed money, so he started selling drugs, and then taking them. Pretty soon, he was addicted to heroin again.
但在那段时期的最后，他父亲去世了。接着，他在一场火灾中损失了大量园艺设备。冬天来了，客户流失。他需要钱，所以他开始贩卖毒品，然后吸毒。没过多久，他再次对海洛因上瘾了。
I was living a double life, you might say. On one hand, I was going to church, being an assistant to the pastor and security and whatnot. And on the other hand, I was on the street selling cocaine and heroin.
我过着双重生活，你可以这么说。一方面，我去教会，做牧师助手，担任安保什么的。另一方面，我在街上卖可卡因和海洛因。
And for a while, it worked out, until my wife drove past me one day on the corner. And it was a [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] me. And she saw me, actually. And I didn't see her, but she saw me. The kids saw me. My in-laws saw me.
有一段时间，这招很管用，直到我妻子有一天开车经过我所在的街角。那是一个（听不清的短语）。她确实看见了我。我没看见她，但她看见了我。孩子们看见了我。我的岳父母看见了我。
What kind of car were they in?
他们开的什么车？
Oh they were in the van.
噢，他们开的是那辆面包车。
Like, the church van.
比如，教会的那辆面包车。
Yeah. And my brother-in-law was driving, and he had to drive past. And they all saw me. And they saw me with a crowd of people in front of me. And I'm telling them, shut up and get in line and be quiet. I got a bunch of money in one hand, and I got the bag of drugs in the other hand. They drove by and saw me stand there, and I never knew it.
是的。我姐夫在开车，他不得不开过去。他们都看见了我。他们看见我面前有一群人。我在对他们说，闭嘴，排好队，安静点。我一只手拿着一大把钱，另一只手拿着一袋毒品。他们开车经过，看见我站在那儿，而我却全然不知。
His wife threatened to leave him if he didn't clean himself up.
妻子威胁说如果他不戒掉毒瘾就离开他。
I'm reading my morning paper, and I'm seeing circles drawn around houses and whatnot.
我在读晨报，看到上面画了圈的房子什么的。
Like she's looking for houses.
就像她在找房子一样。
Yeah. But I didn't believe her, being together almost 20 years. And basically, I came in the house one day. And everything was gone, except my stuff. My stuff was not packed up.
是的。但我没信她，毕竟在一起快20年了。总之，有一天我进了屋子。所有东西都不见了，除了我的个人物品。我的东西没被打包。
So I go to go around my sister-in-laws, my brother-in-laws, to see if they've seen her, because they lived right around the corner. And my wife was there with a big U-Haul truck in front of the house. And I was like, you could have pushed me over with a spoon, and I'd have fell all out in the street. That's how weak in the knees I felt.
所以我去嫂子家、姐夫家看看他们有没有见过她，因为他们就住在拐角处。我妻子在那儿，屋子前停着一辆巨大的U-Haul搬家卡车。我当时心想，用勺子就能把我推倒，我会在街上瘫成一团。我当时感觉膝盖有多软，我就有多绝望。
Were you selling drugs that day?
你那天在卖毒品吗？
Yeah, I was. And I had a crowd of people waiting for me, actually.
是的，我在卖。实际上有一群人在等我。
Crowd of people meaning customers.
那群人是指客户。
Yeah. And a guy came running up the street, he was like, man, [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]. You ain't going to somebody else. I asked my wife, "Won't you let him sit here with you for a minute? I'll be right back. I've got to see about something."
是的。有个家伙冲上街，他说，伙计，（听不清的短语）。你别去别人那儿。我问妻子：“你不能让他在这儿陪你待一会儿吗？我马上回来。我得处理点事。”
And she was like, "Go." And she knew where I was going at that point. She was like, "Go. It doesn't matter. Go ahead."
她却说：“去吧。”那时她知道我要去哪儿。她说：“去吧。没关系。去吧。”
I was like, "now, look, hold this money for me." That was my plan, to get her to hold the money so she couldn't leave. And she was like, "I don't want your money. I don't want anything from you." She was like, "I just want a clean, sober husband." She was like, "You'll be all right. Just do anything, you'll be all right."
我当时说：“看，帮我拿着钱。”我的计划是让她帮我拿着钱，这样她就走不了了。她说：“我不想要你的钱。我不想要你任何东西。”她说：“我只想要一个干净、清醒的丈夫。”她说：“你会没事的。只管去做任何事，你会没事的。”
He ran off to his customers. And when he came back, the U-Haul truck was gone. He asked his brother-in-law if she went to the store or something. He said, no. She had gone to South Carolina.
他跑去见客户了。当他回来时，U-Haul卡车已经不见了。他问姐夫她是不是去商店还是哪儿了。姐夫说，没有。她去南卡罗来纳州了。
I was crying, and falling [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Because I really loved my wife. And that's really hard. That really messed me up a lot, realizing that she was really going.
我在哭，瘫在（听不清）。因为我真的很爱我妻子。那真的很难受。意识到她是真的要走了，这让我受到了很大的打击。
That took out all the reasons that I had for doing what I was doing. That took it away. I didn't want to sell drugs anymore. I didn't want to get high anymore. And at that time, things just fell apart. Everything just fell apart.
那带走了我做那些事的全部理由。那把一切都带走了。我不想再卖毒品了。我不想再吸毒了。在那一刻，一切都分崩离析。一切都散架了。
Very soon after that, you get arrested.
在那之后很快，你就被捕了。
Yeah.
是的。
Just describe what happened that day.
描述一下那一天发生了什么。
Well, that's what I don't remember, exactly. I remember being bombed out of my skull.
嗯，那正是我不记得的确切细节。我记得当时我大脑一片空白。
I was looking at the court files, reviewing your court file. And I found the statement of probable cause from the police. And I just want to read it to you to see if it sounds familiar.
我在查阅法庭档案，审阅你的案件档案。我发现了警察的《可能原因陈述书》。我只是想读给你听，看你熟不熟悉。
"On 14, June 2000, at 1:40 AM, this officer was in the 4900 block of Cordelia Avenue. We were inside our vehicle. The defendant approached this officer and inquired if he may talk to this officer. This officer responded in the affirmative.
“2000年6月14日凌晨1:40，本警官正在Cordelia大道4900街区。我们在警车内。被告走近本警官，询问是否可以与本警官交谈。本警官作了肯定回应。”
At this time, the defendant made a voluntary, uncoerced statement that he would like to turn himself in for possessing the illegal narcotic, cocaine. The defendant further stated that he had this substance in his possession in the right breast pocket of his jacket. The defendant then removed from his right breast jacket pocket 12 blue Ziploc baggies containing white rock substance.
“此时，被告做出自愿、未受胁迫的陈述，表示愿意为持有非法麻醉品可卡因而自首。被告进一步陈述，该物质在他外套右胸口袋中。随后，被告从他外套右胸口袋中取出12个蓝色塑料密封袋，内含白色块状物质。”
The defendant surrendered these items to this officer. At this time, the defendant was placed under arrest. The defendant additionally began to state that he had also committed other serious offenses that he wished to confess."
“被告将这些物品移交给了本警官。此时，被告被逮捕。被告另外开始陈述他还犯有其他希望交代的严重罪行。”
None of that sounds familiar at all.
这些我一点印象都没有。
On June 14, 2000, handcuffed to a steel table in an interrogation room, and throwing up into a garbage pail as the heroin left his system, Randy confessed to the murder of Arnette Hubbard. A detective taking notes during the conversation wrote, "Has been selling coke and dope, selling for anyone he could, tired of game. Feels guilty about doing murder."
2000年6月14日，被铐在审讯室的铁桌上，随着海洛因排出体外，兰迪在呕吐进垃圾桶的同时，供认了谋杀阿内特·哈伯德的罪行。一名在谈话中做记录的警探写道：“一直在卖可卡因和毒品，为任何能卖给的人卖，厌倦了这场游戏。对谋杀感到内疚。”
Randy described the killing down to the smallest detail, the checkered shirt Hubbard had been wearing, the knife that was six or seven inches long. He does not remember telling them a word of this. Not long after, in district court, he waited for his case to come up.
兰迪详细描述了谋杀的每一个小细节，哈伯德穿的格子衬衫，那把六七英寸长的刀。他不记得对他们说过这些。没过多久，在地区法院，他等待着案件审理。
They call your number and your name to stand up for a particular case. And they called my name. And I stood up.
他们叫你的号码和名字来为特定案件出庭。他们叫了我的名字。我站了起来。
When they said first-degree murder, well, I sat back down. Because I was like, "Oh, no, no, that's not my charge." They said, "Yeah, stand up. It is your charge." I'm like, "No, no. I know I may be a bad drug dealer, but I'm not a murderer or something. What are they talking about?"
当他们说一级谋杀时，嗯，我坐下了。因为我想：“哦，不，不，这不是我的指控。”他们说：“是的，站起来。这就是你的指控。”我心想：“不，不。我知道我可能是一个糟糕的毒贩，但我不是杀人犯什么的。他们在说什么？”
At what moment did you realize you had been charged with this murder that you'd committed 20 years before?
你在什么时刻意识到自己被指控犯下了20年前所犯的谋杀案？
It was when I was in the courtroom.
是在法庭上的时候。
You knew it was that, you knew it was Arnette Hubbard.
你知道是那个案件，你知道是阿内特·哈伯德。
They said his name, and I still didn't know who it was, because I had never known his name.
他们说了他的名字，但我还是不知道他是谁，因为我从来不知道他的名字。
Randy initially fought the charges, but ended up pleading guilty to second-degree murder. Baltimore Circuit Judge William D. Quarles sentenced him to 12 years in prison. At the hearing, he said to Randy, "I guess you reassure me, in a sense, of my belief in human nature, because you are obviously someone who developed a sense of conscience. Because you had actually gotten away with it." But if you come clean, never intending to come clean, and not remembering afterwards you've come clean, does that really count as an act of conscience?
兰迪最初对指控进行了辩护，但最终对二级谋杀罪表示认罪。巴尔的摩巡回法官威廉·D·夸尔斯判处他12年监禁。在听证会上，他对兰迪说：“从某种意义上说，你让我重新坚信了人性，因为你显然是一个拥有良知的人。因为你其实已经逃脱了惩罚。”但如果你自首，从未打算过自首，事后也不记得自己自首过，那真的算是一种良知行为吗？
You must think about your own subconscious, the mystery of what made you open your mouth.
你一定常思考自己的潜意识，那个让你开口说话的神秘力量。
Yeah, all the time.
是的，一直都在想。
And have you come to any conclusion?
你得出什么结论了吗？
No. That's not something that I've really come to grips with. I just don't know how to feel, really. It isn't like, "Oh, yeah, confession is good and clean for the soul." No, it feels like, "What a dummy. I should have kept my mouth closed." Don't want to mess up the next 20 years of my life.
没有。那不是我真正能够接受的事情。我真的不知道该有什么感觉。这不像说，“哦，是的，坦白从宽对灵魂好。”不，这感觉像是，“真是个蠢货。我本该闭嘴的。”不想搞砸接下来20年的人生。
So you regret telling them.
所以你后悔告诉他们了。
Yeah, of course.
是的，当然。
It wasn't a relief to tell police, he says. He didn't feel like he'd gotten something off his chest. That feeling came when he told the people who meant something to him, his wife, the members of his church. That feeling came when he squared it with God.
他说是并没有感到坦白后的解脱。那种感觉来自于当他告诉对他有意义的人时，他的妻子，他教会的成员。那种感觉来自于他向上帝交代清楚时。
But somehow the decision to tell police about that night wasn't exactly his. With heroin as its unwitting ally, Randy's conscience, the angel on his shoulder he remembers from childhood cartoons, commandeered the interview, flooring everyone involved. In prison, he's still hearing that voice, and another voice, too.
但不知何故，那个夜晚告诉警察的决定并非完全出于他自己的本意。以海洛因为不自觉的同盟，兰迪的良心——那个他儿时卡通片里记在心头的肩上天使，接管了审讯，震惊了所有人。在监狱里，他依然能听到那个声音，还有另一个声音。
It's kind of hard to explain. I used to sit back and I would hear voices saying-- well, on one hand, it's like, "How do you feel now, dumbass? And look what you got yourself into. Go to trial. Fight it. You can beat this."
这很难解释。我过去常坐着，听到有声音说——一方面，就像是，“感觉怎么样，蠢货？看你把自己搞成了什么样。去审判吧。去抗争。你能赢。”
And then my other shoulder's like, "Don't worry. The Lord is going to be [UNINTELLIGIBLE] sooner than you think. You did the right thing. You can leave here with a clean slate and start your life over."
然后我另一边的肩膀就像是，“别担心。上帝会比你想象的（听不清）更快到来。你做了正确的事。你可以带着清白的记录离开这里，重新开始生活。”
Which side is winning?
哪一边赢了？
Well, currently, clean slate side. You know, "You can leave here with a clean slate now. And things'll get better." And in a way, I believe it. But in a way, I don't.
嗯，目前，清白记录那一侧。你知道，“你现在可以带着清白的记录离开这里了。事情会好起来的。”在某种程度上，我相信。但在某种程度上，我不信。
There's another way to see this whole story, that it wasn't his conscience that made him confess to the police. Randy's sisters see it more as a suicidal act. His wife had left him. He was back on drugs. He had sunk so low that some part of him, and not the angel part, wanted to do something self-destructive. So he told the police.
看待整个故事还有另一种方式，即让他向警察自首的并非他的良心。兰迪的姐妹们将其视为一种自杀行为。他的妻子离开了他。他又吸毒了。他沦落到这种地步，以至于他的一部分——而非天使那部分——想要做出一些自我毁灭的事。于是他告诉了警察。
What's odd is that Randy himself hasn't figured out whether he's a good person who needed to clear his conscience once and for all, or just a drug addict who gave up and ratted himself out. After thinking about it every day for two years in prison, Randy still can't decide.
奇怪的是，兰迪自己还没弄清楚他究竟是一个为了清心最终需要坦白的善良人，还是仅仅是一个放弃了自己、出卖了自己的瘾君子。在监狱里思考了两年，每天都在想，兰迪仍然无法决定。
Sarah Koenig.
萨拉·科尼格。
Production help today from Flawn Williams and the charming Jorge Just and Aaron Scott. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. He's feeling so good ever since he came back from the hairstylist at the mall. Here's why.
今天的制作协助来自弗隆·威廉姆斯，迷人的乔治·贾斯特和阿伦·斯科特。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。我们的节目由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责管理监督。自从他从商场的发型师那儿回来，他就感觉太棒了。原因如下。
I went and got rid of my Amish haircut, went and got rid of my Amish clothes.
我去剪掉了我的阿米什发型，扔掉了我的阿米什衣服。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International. international
PRI，公共广播国际公司。国际